okay everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie I'm Jessie and this is
Cordelia you say hi and we can do some
coding yeah all right so a little update
on a few things so if you follow me on
Twitter you've seen some of the tweets
that I was putting out there were about
my streaming setup at home so I I did
everything I got it an old PC that I
used to use for for development but I
haven't used in years
got it up spent a really long time
updating it because it evidently it
takes forever to run updates if you
haven't updated it years so update it at
all got everything set up on my macbook
which is what I normally use and the PC
and then it turns out that I was trying
to use something a plug-in called NDI
for OBS which is my streaming software
and it doesn't work with a lot of AMD
processors and I happen to have one of
the processes that it doesn't work with
so didn't get it to work so if today's
stream is a little bit slow apologize I
worked I worked hard on trying to fix
that so I'm not sure what the next step
is in terms of a solution I'd love to be
able to use my my webcam that's much
better than the built-in camera but my
macbook can't handle it
so I have to come up with something else
I mean it maybe if I just get really
cheap
Windows machine that has an Intel
processor I could offload a lot of the
streaming stuff onto that I don't know
we'll see but for today we're gonna work
on our routing so let me get this up on
the other screen and then I'll switch
over to that alright so this is our on
the left is our server ojs file and this
is where we have our custom router so
I've gone over this before on the stream
if anyone really wants me to go into it
in more detail let me know we can do
that in the question-and-answer portion
of the stream which will come at the end
and otherwise I'm just gonna kind of
briefly explain what we're doing and
then on the right we have our our data
for our main menu that that's in that
side drawer and we have it looks a
little bit different than normal links
so in order to have our client side
routing work we need to add in some
extra information so that's why we have
you know this not only this link URL but
then an as URL so we need to tell okay
by Cordelia so yeah Cordelia it's at
least you won't be joining us for the
rest of the stream her mom figured out
that she had snuck down here so she was
still in pretty good though she wasn't
trying to press the keys I don't know
maybe she could have stayed but anyway
that's why we're gonna have have to add
in a little bit more information so
basically what we need to do is tell
our router exactly what information we
need and what component it needs to
render so normally if you go straight to
the site like you type in a URL all of
it is handled by this router here but if
you try to do client-side routing
obviously like it bypasses our server
side routing right so we need to handle
that over here as well so it's a little
bit of extra work but I think it's it's
what we have to do to make sure that all
the URLs from the old site work on the
new site as well okay let's get to it
seems like we have a lot fewer viewers
than normal I'm wondering what wonder
did anybody get a notification I didn't
get a notification from the stream
saying that it was gonna start maybe
maybe that's the problem
so usually when that happens in a
notification doesn't go out then we a
lot of people don't know so I did throw
something on Twitter and on Instagram
but I don't think I can manually make a
notification go out so I'm just gonna
get started I was just kind of waiting a
little bit see if we get you know our
normal amount of viewers but I'm just
gonna get started with this so I will
have a Pomodoro timer and I'm just gonna
let it go on my other screen here and
then let's jump right into what I was
working on before I started the stream
and that is I'm just going through let's
shrink this down a bit we really want
you
use this at all maybe at the end would
be able to get commit but I'm going
through our data all our links for that
side navigation menu and all Phoenix
mentioned it's it's past 1:00 a.m. and
India you know I've been exact I totally
forgot about that you're right I I do
have a decent amount of viewers who are
nearly on the other side of the world
from me and it is really late for them
so that that probably explains why we
don't have at least why we do part of
why we don't have as many viewers as
normal let's see just trying to find
where I left off at okay so it looks
like we have minor programming our minor
programs works that link works our
academic advising I'm having trouble
finding this data so I may not have
transferred this data yet so we're just
gonna skip that for now and I'm already
made a note to check that out so student
academic support services let's see if
we have we have anything so all of our
if you want to check out the server Jas
file the link to the repos in the
description to the video so you can
check that out and just go you know
right to server Jas this is all right on
the master branch but all of you know
the actual logic is down here but up top
here we have a large array that gets
searched through to determine based on
the URL what needs to be rendered what
data do we need to get from WordPress
and what component
need to be rendered so that's what all
this data is here so let me I guess I
should just do a search because this is
getting quite large and I want to see
this
I believe the URL would be si SS and
what I've been doing and let me pull
some of this over some of the stuff I've
been working on on this other screen
what I've been doing is searching just
to be sure so in this instance check
back here okay so I believe we're in
academics in undergraduate we have these
submenus which we ended up taking in on
this is the current site like the main
site for the university that worked for
as it is now so instead of having these
menus here we move them to be a part of
our side navigation which is nice
because then you can get to them from
any other page on the site it saves you
having to load another page but this is
what we're trying to get to the student
academic support services so we need a
route so that people can get to this
page on the new site
so we have our URL they need to be able
to get to this URL but also once I
accidentally clicked on actually it
looks like there are sub pages as well
good to know
lots of sub pages
okay so we have to be aware of those sub
pages and what we'll do first is let me
pull over another page here and you know
roasters cleaning up some data so let's
see if we have anything here and there
are only about twenty entries here so
they can just scan through quickly
and it looks like we may not have we may
not even have this data yet which is
okay if that's the case we can grab that
data later on and just make a note of it
but we can still create a route we just
won't be able to test the route right
now
so what I'll do is make note of this URL
and this route and then on my other
screen I have a to-do list so I'm just
gonna pop this in its to-do list
Wow and my to-do list thing is seems to
take up quite a bit of quite a bit of
computing power I can hear my gonna hear
my laptop running a lot more loudly so
I'm just gonna close that down and let's
make a route for this so that we have it
even though we can't test it so whenever
someone types in si SS we need to direct
them somewhere
Oh
so let's just let's grab something so
that we don't have to type it all out
we're gonna copy and paste so what we're
gonna do this first part is and this is
how we set up our router not every
custom router has to work like this but
in the context of what we've done we're
gonna say if somebody happens to type in
si SS and I believe I've already set
this up so that the case does not matter
so this is case insensitive so if
someone types this in what we want to do
is have the component that gets rendered
be the page component and then we don't
have a post type yet but we're going to
anticipate creating a new post type for
this so this would be I don't even
remember what that was student academic
support services so for now I'm going to
anticipate we will create that post type
because it looks like there that maybe
for at least four sub pages that I can
see so that may be a good candidate to
be its own post type of its own section
so we're going to create that at some
point maybe not in the stream today
we'll see I mean I suppose maybe we
could let me know what you all think if
you'd like to go through the steps of
creating that or not and then for the ID
we'll stick with the default being named
so what we'll do is the main page will
give it the slug of main in WordPress so
we'll say that and now we'll move on
right because we don't have that dais
there's not really anything else we can
do about that although what we can do is
is I guess we can change this here so
it's going to be age type the ID name
there we go
now Writing Center is another one of
those where I don't know that the data
has has come over yet we can double
check though actually there's a link to
it here so I'm just gonna go here
regardless of whether or not we have the
data transferred it still needs to be
added to the router John Hanson says so
now you're using sass for your styling I
would prefer to use as for the styling
actually I just never took the time to
set it up
Oh world's asked do you use Express with
WordPress so the Express is a separate
part of it so our Express code which is
I mean Express for those of you who
aren't sure what's what's happening here
we're using JavaScript on the server
okay using something called nodejs which
allows you to use JavaScript server-side
there is a library or plugin wherever
you want to call it that works with
nodejs called Express it's very common
it may be the most common plugin that
people use or library that people use
with node and it helps like any
JavaScript library it helps to simplify
things makes it easier to work with it
so we're using that in our survey ojs
file to help us out
to create a custom routing solution for
our react site where WordPress comes in
is we have a separate WordPress
installation that lives elsewhere on a
totally different server and we have
graph QL running on that server which
means we can use Apollo which which is
another library that we were
with to make graph QL queries to our
wordpress installation and get data back
so Express does work with WordPress but
in to let in directly right through
intermediaries here so we're we don't
directly have you know Express on a
WordPress server or anything like that
okay so we have the Writing Center page
and that's it looks like there are no
sub pages for the Writing Center so this
would probably be a better candidate to
yeah this would be a better candidate to
reside elsewhere I'm meaning like it
doesn't need its own post site it can
reside inside of another post type and
I'll show you you know what I mean so on
the side here this might be hard to see
let me increase the font size a bit so
on the side here all different post
types so probably that student academic
services student academic support
services that's probably where this
Writing Center should live in there but
I really would like to show you what
happens when we have real data and we
make a route so let's add into the
academics pages because it I mean it
makes sense there at least for now we
can always move it later but in the
academics pages let's add manually
another post type so I'm not gonna
bother trying to go to the database and
pull the data in we're just gonna do
copy and paste just to get this working
so we're gonna add a new page and let's
call this
Writing Center and we're gonna paste
this and let's paste this in here there
we go and then we we keep our formatting
when I originally pasted it I went into
this text thing and you see we had no
formatting no tags
if you taste paste it into the visual
tab in WordPress it pulls over a lot of
the formatting so let's see I wonder if
the alright yet so the notification
finally went out that the stream was
happening so the viewer account just
jumped up so hello everyone if for those
are you just joining us which is most of
you we're doing some routing we're
working with our router so I'm just
putting in some data so we can create a
route and then I actually navigate to it
and see the data there so I will need to
do something about you know these these
links I need to add the links in
somewhere so I'm not gonna worry about
that right now but for now let's add a
slug and we'll just call this writing
writing center so I did put the title
yep writing center so let's publish this
so it'll be available now great ok now
let's go back to our a router here so if
we take let's go yeah let's go here and
copy and paste this because we won't
need to change much so this is already
set up to work with the same post type
so let's grab this and change it to
Writing Center
all right and I'll take a second to
explain this so what's gonna happen now
is I'm gonna let it donato format what's
gonna happen now is if somebody types in
a URL that when the site launches it'll
be Franciscan ddu slash Writing Center
then our router is gonna search through
this array find Writing Center and then
now it's gonna know okay we need to
render the component called page it is
the post type of academic pages so we're
gonna need to make a graph QL call to
search through academic pages and then
within there we would want to search for
the academic page with a slug of Writing
Center so that's what each of these mean
so when we say here that this has this
this default I'm not gonna get into deep
into that right now but in our router we
have several like options for some kind
of odd routes that we've had to deal
with but for right now this is just you
know pretty simple so now that I've say
that we should be able to navigate
directly to whether that here we go we
should be able to navigate on localhost
Writing Center since I'm running this
locally or let's make sure I am running
this okay I am
make sure I saved it
okay and let's try it again
localhost refused to connect let's just
try to get to local look no it didn't
let's see alright wow look Louis is not
working and what happened let's restart
the server then because it should be
working let's give it a click let's see
if we can
[Music]
it's just not giving us an air
immediately I guess that's good okay
it's it looks like it's fish it's
building the page in about five minutes
I'm gonna go to the live chat and answer
questions if you if you asking some
questions just you know hang in there ah
this is really odd oh wow that was
taking a really long time
so at the beginning in the stream most
of you weren't there but it'd be
beginning in a stream I was explaining
that I did have a plan to increase the
streaming performance and it failed
because I don't have the right processor
on the PC I was trying to stream from so
anyway I need to come up with a
different plan so for now my computer is
very sluggish when I'm running the
stream and I can't use my better webcam
okay so now let's try to go to writing
center to verify that the route that we
just made works
this may end up being a shorter stream
if if our if this is running so slowly
there we are
awesome okay so we have our Writing
Center information that we had just
created this in WordPress and now it's
being pulled in through graph QL and
Apollo into our react site and so now we
have it we have Writing Center but we
have a problem
so that was wonderful if we navigated
directly to it but what if I what if I
go over here in my side menu and I go
down here to academics into I believe
undergraduate and then I want to click
on Writing Center well right now it
takes me to the wrong URL anyway but
then also I can't get the info I want so
let's let's check that out
so here right now we are going in the
wrong place so let's change our URL to
Writing Center but that's not enough
since this is going to be when we click
on that that's going to be a client-side
route so it's not ever gonna hit the
server and load from the server there's
gonna be no page refresh so everything
we've done here basically it's not going
to apply so we need to mimic what we've
done here over here in our data for this
and so we're gonna take pretty much
exactly where their academic pages are
right and we're gonna say what ID do we
want and that ID translates into what
slug do we need to search for in
WordPress under the tie
the post type of academic pages so let's
go Writing Center and we're gonna save
that and I'm gonna give it a second
since it was so slow earlier
yeah all right so let's go back in here
and let's click here an undergraduate
and now let's check out our Writing
Center link and it worked this time
actually navigate somewhere else because
we were already on that page so it
really wasn't impressive nothing
actually changed
Writing Center there we are and it went
right there so very quick client-side
routing and I don't know I don't think
it's set up when we when we serve this
locally but in a production environment
a lot of this information would be
cached so we're gonna by doing it like
this instead of just allowing it to fall
back and do a page refresh on the server
we're gonna see significant speed
increases so running locally you don't
really see it that much but it's it's
gonna be worth the effort in terms of
user experience and performance okay and
my timer just went up my Pomodoro timer
so I'm gonna now go to the chat and try
to answer as many of your questions as I
can and I may or may not do another
Pomodoro session I I'd like to do more
but it's just the my computer's running
so slow it's it's just kind of painful
to wait to see if these things are
working okay
renato says hey Jesse sorry don't want
to bother your work don't worry about
that if questions are always welcome
just wanted to ask are you using a mic
to stream I'm thinking streaming coding
myself also as a laptop okay yes so I'm
streaming from a laptop right now from
the MacBook Pro I'm using the built-in
microphone so it works when I stream
from my office though I get a much
better you know quality stream and from
my office I'm currently using an
external microphone that plugs in by USB
and I'm also using a USB webcam the
the razor kiyo webcam so I've my streams
from my office are so much better right
now than what I can do from a laptop so
it is possible to stream from a laptop
but unless you had a really really good
laptop you're probably not gonna get
great quality in your stream both in
terms of video quality you know you know
like whether you can get 1080 p or 720
or whatever and in terms of just the
what your machine can handle my machine
obviously is slowed down significantly
when I'm not streaming everything just
runs super quickly
I never have any lag as soon as I start
streaming everything slows down to a
crawl so that's just something to you
know keep in mind I'm sure it does
really depend on how powerful your
laptop is
Bhargav says what software do you use
obs okay Renato is talking about sorry
without the camera yeah you can stream
if you don't include the camera you
should get be able to get away with
having a little bit less in terms of you
know the RAM on your machine it there's
definitely a difference in like how much
CPU gets used if you have OBS it'll show
you the percentage of the CPU that gets
used so depending on what you're doing
and if you have that camera there it
does use more right now I'm just using
the built-in camera it seems that an
external USB camera it uses even more
CPU at least that's just been my
experience
and then just said oh cool this is for
legit uni yeah for sure I've all the
projects we do here are real projects
that are that are either live right now
and we're improving or are gonna go live
this particular project is scheduled to
be live on June 4th this is coming soon
Phoenix says so jesse is a laptop with 8
gigabytes of RAM a 4 gigabyte nvidia gtx
1050 with i7 processor good enough
machine or do I need something more I I
think that you should be able to get
away with it with with that machine you
know what let's bring up the the specs
for this machine now and just to compare
so right now that's probably too small
for you all to see but oh so I'll read
it off as well this is the MacBook Pro
Retina the 13-inch early 2015 model so
it has a 2.7 gigahertz Intel Core i5 so
if you had the i7 you know you're
already doing better than I'm doing
right now and it has the 8 gigabytes of
memory so I would say yeah definitely
you you should be able to stream with a
laptop the as you described it's gonna
be better than what I have right now
and right now is it's not ideal but it
is possible for me to stream from this
laptop
Julia says react me I'm not I'm not sure
what that question is Julia if you could
explain a little bit more I'd be happy
to give you an answer John says will the
caching of the many pages from the
WordPress server be using prefetch or
something else yeah so a lot of that
will be using prefetch so whatever links
and I can kind of show this this
actually might be really appropriate to
show right now is you know where this
data is going into in terms of like what
component is using this data and that's
where that prefetching is gonna happen
to so let's check it out we need to go
to our drawer let's see our components
and let's go to our drawer item so each
item in the drawer is a has a link so
we're bringing in link from next link so
this comes with next j/s which is what
we're using with react next jf has some
really nice things in there it does come
with some routing with routing right out
of the box we're not really utilizing
that since we did a custom routing but
it has server-side rendering setup by
default which is amazing so it saves us
time from having to try to do that on
our own and one of the things that it
does have is this link component and you
can put prefetch on that and so for our
prefetching what we have now set is for
all these links over here it's if
item as URL so if this as URL is there
then it prefetches if we do not put this
piece of data in there a dozen prefetch
so all of these will be pre fetched and
we also have some logic here to with our
turn areas to determine like what should
the HRF be this is because mixed in with
these internal links we do have some
external links which we want to be
treated differently so that's why we
need to do this so you can see our href
may end up being our link URL or are as
URL depending on whether or not this as
you are always present and if so I guess
I didn't really explain the prefetching
so what it what this does here what next
Jes does here is that when your page
loads its gonna look at all the links
that have that prefetch attribute and it
is going to get the data to load those
pages in the background using the
serviceworker a serviceworker is a
javascript file that just kind of sits
in the background in the browser and it
can do things that won't block the
rendering of the page so in this case
what it's doing is it's grabbing the
data it's loading that data and just
saving it in waiting so that if a user
clicks on one of those links that we've
prefetched the data is already ready and
it just increases those load times so
they're pretty much instantaneous
because that data is already there and
like I said because it doesn't block any
of the rendering
you know the user doesn't even know
there's no like performance issues with
all this stuff floating in the
background so really cool useful we've
done this before on a site that we
launched and in Google Analytics when we
checked our load times for a lot of the
interior pages the load time was zero
zero seconds because we had already pre
fetched it so everything was ready there
was literally nothing to load so really
cool when when this works out so we're
gonna have I've already I already have a
test version of this that is live and it
just has you know one of those now URLs
so that now dot sh man it has a bunch of
string so I'm gonna get a more normal
looking URL set up for that now I use
that as an alias and then you all I'll
put that in the description of the video
so you all can check it out whenever you
want test it and then you'll be able to
really see the speed that this site has
when we use that prefetching Goku asks
which database we're using so we're
using a my sequel database that's
connected to a wordpress installation
and that's the new database currently
for the the old version of the site
that's still running right now it's a
sequel server database so I've been
migrating all the data from there and
putting it into the my sequel database
so normally with WordPress you use my
sequel or you can use Maria DB default
for WordPress is my sequel go cool ask
which back-end framework is better so if
you're I guess if you're talking about
back-end I it depends on what language
you're using so
with ya era I'm sorry with node so with
JavaScript as your back-end language
then Express seems to be you know the
one that everybody is using it's not the
only one but I don't having any
experience with any other hmm excuse me
sorry
I don't have experience with other
back-end frameworks for that if you're
talking about you know different
languages there's there's a lot of
different options so I don't know
exactly what's better look for PHP what
do people use laravel said that the PHP
framework that's pretty popular I don't
remember what the Python one is called I
never use it so I don't really remember
but mainly when we work with node we're
almost always using Express maybe all
these I actually I can't recall a time
when I've except for like very simple
things I can't really recall it Center
that I haven't used Express with with
node
miss miss state says watching this for
the first time can you briefly tell what
you were doing okay yes so right now I
was working on using nodejs to do some
custom routing so like basically when
you're when you try to browse to a
certain page on the website write a
request gets sent to the server so we're
using node to take that request break it
down and say okay what data do I need to
send back to the user right so we were
just kind of making those routes we're
coding in what needs to be done the goal
is to make sure that the routes for this
new website match up exactly with the
routes that are currently exist on the
old website it's a little bit tricky
because there's not like a unified
system that really makes sense
so we keep having to adapt our router
for all these different exceptions so if
you check out the server dot j s file in
the project it is quite large and the
reason being that we we need to be able
to adapt to all these different
scenarios so that's like very very short
explanation of what we're doing
Big Daddy says hello world hello John
says thanks I'd forgotten you use next J
s here doing the prefetching by hand
coding in JavaScript is a lot harder oh
yeah for sure I'm I don't even want to
attempt to try to do prefetching by aunt
Nikki says hey everyone just reformatted
PC how do I open a specific video in
Chrome again without the window dressing
like URL bar navigation icons and
bookmarks you mean like a YouTube video
so should be a little icon in the bottom
right hand corner to be able to do that
John Hanson says if you could I know
it's almost impossible now but to start
all over with a blockchain database be
easier to maintain and build on I
wouldn't do blockchain for this the
reason being for blockchain a lot of
things that you do with law chain
require is it has a cost right so like
if you don't like a theorem it has like
they call it a gas cost so like if I
build it on the ethereum blockchain then
certain interactions would cost the user
ether to be able to do no on a site like
this I'm I'm not sure I haven't even
considered building just a regular
website that wouldn't really have a lot
of user interaction
on blockchain so I hadn't really thought
about it but that's a definitely a big
consideration though is will this so
number one consideration is how much is
this gonna cost users but number two is
speed blockchain apps right now are
almost always slower than their
equivalents that are non blockchain and
the reason being like the calculations
that need to be done on all the
different nodes in the chain you have to
verify transactions are by design hard
they're very difficult to do so it takes
a while so anyway yeah if we're gonna do
anything with blockchain then it that
has to be considered so there needs to
be a really good reason of why do we
need this to be decentralized on on the
blockchain you know what's the value to
a user of this being decentralized so in
with this type of website right now I
don't really see that there would be any
value added by doing things on a
blockchain
Fortunato says are the routes programmed
and configured on the node side or
client-side with react router so we're
not running react router but see how so
all the routes are configured on the
server side but we do have client-side
routing happening as well okay and a lot
of that's taken care of with next but
what we need to do is tell our
components what to render so we do have
to give some extra information to get
that client-side routing working because
we still need to grab data from from
WordPress using graph QL so graph QL
needs to know what post type do we need
to get and it needs to know what is the
slug what is the ID for that post so
even if we're gonna do client-side
routing we still need to supply that
data so that data is supplied on the
server side it's supplied to the router
via the URL and then we have an array
that has key value pairs of the URL
being the key and then we specify okay
what other data needs to be given to the
router and used to do our graph QL query
on that's on the server side on the
client side you know we have you know
this on the left-hand side which
basically with our link components we
pass in what data we need in addition to
the normal URL
Oh Nicky said basically I used to watch
these streams almost fullscreen video
left chat right with the window options
the video is so small also shows
description video etc hmm I'm certain
I'm not exactly sure what how to get it
like full screen with the chat and
everything like like you want Thank You
dragon hunter says where's the beard I
shaved off the beard starting to get
warmer outside shaved it also my wife
hates my beard so the problem now is
when it gets a little bit of stubble
like I have today my my 3 year old he
complains that my chin hurts him so when
he's trying to cuddle with me my chin
hurts so I probably should save this
stubble offered he's gonna be so sad
John says isn't the better part of
blockchain is that it keeps integrity of
information over time for university
that may be somewhat important yeah for
sure so as I was explaining everything
with the blockchain it did occur to me
that you know potentially it might not
be a bad idea to look into blockchain
you know for data right you have this
persistent immutable storage that's
untouchable you obeyed by any regulatory
agencies or anything like that so
there's definitely an advantage I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to let's say
run a website straight from that data
but to use it in some other capacity
yeah maybe maybe there'd be some value
to that I need to look into that more
and think more about it but I mean I
think you do have a good point there
dragon hunter says looks very young
without the beard
yeah I do end up looking a lot younger
without my beard
especially because there are gray hairs
in my beard but I don't have any gray on
my head yet so definitely look look a
lot older with a beard okay mm-hmm let's
uh I think I'm gonna end the stream here
unless there's any other questions that
are gonna come in in the next minute or
so so I mean the streams not been going
on for about an hour don't really want
to have to fight with this really slow
machine I'll be back in the office
tomorrow so be able to do a nice quality
stream tomorrow and then I'll just I I
really need to see I need to check out
some prices to see if if there's a
reasonably priced PC that has an Intel
processor so that I can do the streaming
like I was going to yeah I really hate
to buy another computer just for that
but that may end up being the only
option that I have I certainly can't add
RAM to a macbook that they don't make it
so that that can work so I don't know
maybe there's yeah unless there's some
other option that I've never heard of
then maybe that might be the best way to
do it
see this miss state says I'm not sure to
pronounce that - so let me know if this
is the wrong pronunciation but anyway
they say where are you streaming from I
mean which place right now I'm streaming
from home so stream quality is not
nearly as good as it it will be tomorrow
when I streamed from my office dragon oh
just says assemble one from use parts
yeah I could try I've done that before
it is really fun it definitely takes a
lot longer the so I just I kind of want
to just get this going fast you know
what I do have one other computer that's
older and slower that but it still might
be it might work I guess it's worth a
shot before I buy another one I'd hate
to use it though it's just my kids use
it it's like one of those all-in-one
touchscreens it was really one of the
first all-in-one touchscreens you could
buy I'll have to see what kind of
processor that has it may not even be
worth it it may just be too old alma
states is which country from the United
States I'm streaming from the from the
US
okay all right well thank you all for
joining me
sorry about the late notification I
don't really have control over that but
it does seem like if I schedule the
stream earlier that doesn't happen as
much also sorry about this the
sluggishness of the machine I'm still
working on that I'm definitely gonna try
to find some solution to get a better
stream quality I will be back in the
office tomorrow so hopefully we'll have
a nicer stream better quality and until
then have a wonderful day